[Music]
2,300 years ago the rulers of Alexandria
set out to fulfill one of humanity's
most audacious goals to collect all the
knowledge in the world under one roof in
its prime the Library of Alexandria
housed an unprecedented number of
Scrolls and attracted some of the Greek
world's greatest minds but by the end of
the fifth century CE II the great
library had vanished many believed it
was destroyed in a catastrophic fire the
truth of the library's rise and fall is
much more complex the idea for the
library came from Alexander the Great
after establishing himself as a
conqueror the former student of
Aristotle turned his attention to
building an empire of knowledge
headquartered in his namesake City he
died before construction began but his
successor Ptolemy the first executed
Alexander's plans from museum and
library located in the royal district of
the city the Library of Alexandria may
have been built with grand Hellenistic
columns native Egyptian influences or a
unique blend of the two there are no
surviving accounts of its architecture
we do know it had lecture halls
classrooms and of course shelves as soon
as the building was complete Ptolemy the
first began to fill it with primarily
Greek and Egyptian Scrolls he invited
scholars to live and study in Alexandria
at his expense the library grew as they
contributed their own manuscripts but
the rulers of Alexandria still wanted a
copy of every book in the world
luckily Alexandria was a hub for ships
traveling through the Mediterranean
Ptolemy the third instituted a policy
requiring any ship that docked in
Alexandria to turn over its books for
copying once the library scribes had
duplicated the texts they kept the
originals and sent the copies back to
the ship's hired book hunters also
scoured the Mediterranean in search of
new texts and the rulers of alexandria
attempted to quash rivals by ending all
exports of the Egyptian papyrus used to
make Scrolls these efforts brought
hundreds of thousands of books to
Alexandria
as the library grew it became possible
to find information on more subjects
than ever before but also much more
difficult to find information on any
specific subject luckily a scholar named
callimachus of cyrene II set to work on
a solution creating the pin X a hundred
and twenty volume catalogue of the
library's contents the first of its kind
using the pin --ax others were able to
navigate the library's swelling
collection they made some astounding
discoveries sixteen hundred years before
Columbus set sail
Aristophanes not only realized the earth
was round but calculated its
circumference and diameter within a few
miles of their actual size Heron of
Alexandria created the world's first
steam engine over a thousand years
before it was finally reinvented during
the industrial revolution for about
three hundred years after its founding
in 283 BCE the library thrived but then
in 48 BCE Julius Caesar laid siege to
Alexandria and set the ships in the
harbor on fire for years scholars
believe the library burned as the blaze
spread into the city it's possible the
fire destroyed part of the sprawling
collection but we know from ancient
writings the scholars continued to visit
the library for centuries after the
siege ultimately the library slowly
disappeared as the city change from
Greek to Roman Christian and eventually
Muslim hands each new set of rulers
viewed its contents as a threat rather
than a source of pride in 415 C II the
Christian rulers even had a
mathematician named Hypatia murdered for
studying the library's ancient Greek
texts which they viewed as blasphemous
though the Library of Alexandria and his
countless texts are long gone we're
still grappling with the best ways to
collect access and preserve our
knowledge there's more information
available today and more advanced
technology to preserve it that we can't
know for sure that our digital archives
will be more resistant to destruction
than Alexandria's ink and paper scrolls
and even if our reservoirs of knowledge
are physically secure they will still
have to resist the more insidious forces
that tore the library apart fear of
knowledge and the arrogant belief that
the past is obsolete the difference is
that this time we know what to prepare
for
[Music]